[Musique]
c'est une chanson extraordinaire et je
venais juste comme ça j'ai dû l'écrire
au moins de dix minutes
bart ça n'a pas pris dix minutes pour
écrire cette chanson mais des années de
vie raconte moi d'où elle vient
je n'ai jamais raconté mon histoire qui
ce soir
quand j'avais 10 ou 11 ans la vie était
dure
oui maman elle s'étire ai dit si elle
veut plus de moi elle veut plus de toi
non plus j'ai toujours adoré la musique
j'ai trouvé quelques chansons auxquelles
je me suis accroché elles m'ont donné de
l'espoir
je suis épaté ça n'est pas sa vraie voir
que j'entends parce qu'il me fallait je
peux y arriver bah non tu ne peux pas
quand ouvrira les yeux tu te rendras
compte que tu seras nulle part tout ça
parce que tu auras voulu poursuivre un
rêve absurde je m'en vais shannon
je veux que tu saches que je prie pour
toi tout le temps
et j'espère que quoi que tu cherches tu
le trouveras
qu'est-ce que tu essaies de fuir mon
père alors écrit là-dessus
tu doit transformer toute cette douleur
en inspiration
il faut que je règle certaines choses et
je le fais de la seule façon que je
connais c'est en écrivant une chanson
tu as faim j'ai mis la table ça veut
dire quoi ça je veux réparer mes erreurs
c'est elle qui a tant fait souffrir
argument
mon père était un monstre et j'ai vu le
seigneur le transformer
[Musique]
toi tu indo vrai nom
je croyais pas que tu pouvais faire ça
j'ai écrit cette chanson pour mon père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]